Hey, jetzt kommen die Ferrero-Tördels, Superlexe Ferrero-Tördels, jeder kennt die Ferrero-Tördels, immer ganz fantastisch. Sie sind echt ein sehr schlaghaftes Team, mit Logo, wenn sie gegen Frust und Hunger ziehen, Kalorien sind in Sachen, sie sind Kühlschrank-Filmstars, die Ferr-Jungs holen Dichter raus. Jeder kennt die Ferrero-Tördels, super lecker Ferrero-Tördels, Raffaello mit Mandelkerl und Stolien-Roschidler, und rück' uns hier ein Nestlick, Küsschen kämpft nach Kinder-Buenos-Platt, gibt's in Dunkel und in Helle, und wird's im Sommer knapp, Sommerpause, zweiwar Ferro-Jungs machen niemals Klopps. Hey, jetzt kommen die Ferro-Tunters, jeder kennt die Ferro-Tunters, die Galekte Ferro-Tunters, immer ganz fantastisch. Es ist immer viel zu haschig. Sorry, ich hab mich verschluckt. Hey! Hallo, herzlich willkommen. Schön, dass ihr da seid. Vielen Dank für diesen Einstieg auf einen Gag, den ich leider nicht mehr im Kopf habe, ehrlich gesagt. Doch, die Ferrero-Turtles. Raffaello, weil du dich versprochen hast. Ach, jetzt, Adler, habe ich's, okay. Raffaello, Raffaello, Ferrero, Stimmt. Und wir hatten Ferrero, Amicelli, genau, Bueno, Bueno, Bueno, Bueno, Giotto. Bueno, Amicelli, wie heißt der andere noch mal? Ich habe das letzte Jahr komplett. Küsschen war da der andere. Küsschen war der mit den zwei langen Schwertern, war das, der blaue. Das war Küsschen. Mit den wundervollen Lippen. Du, ich stehe schon so in 2025 drin, Stefan, knietief. Du stehst. Wirklich, ich habe das bis in die Hose drin. Ich kann mich wirklich an 2024 nicht mehr erinnern. Was war da? Mir egal, alles hinter mir gelassen. Ich schaue in Rückspiegel. Wir gehen direkt rein in Medias Rees. Florentil, was wird dieses Jahr anders? Ey, dieses Jahr wird alles anders. Was ist der Florentil in 2025? Ich bin entspannt, ich bin locker, ich werde mich tatsächlich ein wenig ändern, denn tatsächlich, ihr habt es wahrscheinlich mitbekommen, 2024 wurde ich sehr oft kritisiert. Von wem? Ich wurde sehr oft von dir zum Beispiel. Ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel noch an Essen, als wir unsere Improv-Show gemacht haben. Wir können gleich ja noch mal zum Jahresrück kommen. Und da waren wir wirklich so zehn Minuten bevor wir auf die Bühne gegangen, beide nervös und du so
ach so, das willst du anziehen auf der Bühne?
Das war eine Frage.
Es war eine offene Frage.
Aber du bist mittlerweile so gut geschult, dass du
auch Kritik als
Frage verteidigst. Und jetzt, Achtung,
trage ich eine schicke
Jogginghose. Mir wurde von einer
Kollegin, von einer Kostümbildnerin
gesagt, hey, und vor allem das Geile ist so, ich nehme von jedem Menschen Kleidungskommentare als Beleidigung wahr, aber nicht von Kostümbildnern. Warum denn von mir? Die haben automatisch Freifahrtschein. Ja, aber auch ich ziehe ja seit nunmehr 30 Jahren Dinge an. Ja. Also ich habe sehr viel Erfahrung im Dinge anziehen. Richtig. Und Dinge kaufen,
um sie anzuziehen. Genau. Warum,
wenn ich dich einfach eine offene Frage stelle,
ist das dein fucking Ernst?
Weil dieses Outfit dein
scheiß Ernst? Genau, es ist eine Frage, aber
warum kommt es als Kritiker? Ja, aber es ist eine Frage,
es schwingt eine starke Aussage mit,
weil das Problem ist, nämlich der Unterschied
zwischen dir und mir ist, du hast Anspruch,
dir ist nicht egal, was du trägst, mir ist vollkommen egal, was ich trage, offensichtlich, Und dann ist es auch ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, zwischen dir und mir ist, du hast Anspruch, dir ist nicht egal, was du trägst, mir ist vollkommen egal, was ich trage, offensichtlich, und jetzt habe ich aber auch gelernt, schicke Mode muss nicht gleich unbequem sein, und deswegen habe ich jetzt mir schicke Jogginghosen gekauft, ich glaube, das ist ein Umschwung, weil modisch, finde ich, kann man immer ganz gut Lebensabschnitte klären. klären. Wenn ich alte Bilder von mir anschaue, es gab die Zipperphase bei mir. Ja, die habe ich jetzt auch wieder.
Hast du wieder? Modisch, finde ich, kann man immer ganz gut Lebensabschnitte klären. Wenn ich alte Bilder von mir anschaue, es gab die Zipperphase bei mir.
Ja, die habe ich jetzt auch wieder.
Hast du wieder?
Manche Zipper in Essen erst hatte ich den Zipper an.
Ach was.
Mag ich wieder sehr.
Ich habe alle Zipper aussortiert irgendwann, dann hatte ich die Pulliphase, dann hatte ich die Hoodiephase, nee Pulliphase, dann gab es.
Was ich jetzt an habe, ist ein Strick Pulli.
Ohne Kapuze.
Sweater. Pulli, jetzt Hoodie. Jetzt bin ich in der Hoodie-Phase und jetzt kommt die nächste Phase mit den schicken Jogginghosen. Ich bin komplett revolutioniert, ich bin ein neuer Mensch. Kannst du die Brand verraten? Nein, ich weiß es tatsächlich nicht. Ist mir komplett egal. Ich habe das eingetippt, einfach mal querbeet bestellt und bin sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr glücklich. Tatsächlich wollte ich dir zu Weihnachten eigentlich geschenkt haben die Schicken-Jogginghosen. Weil ich habe mich erinnert, dass du gesagt hast, dass du die Schicken-Jogginghosen in dein Leben getreten sind als Vorschlag. Dann wollte ich das eigentlich machen, aber jetzt hast du die schon. Stattdessen hast du rückblickend was geschenkt? Äh, nichts. Gar nichts, ja genau. Ja, weil dann, ich finde, wir schenken uns ja eher was, wenn die eine gute Idee. Achtes Jahr in Folge. Ja, weil du hast mir auch nichts geschenkt. Ja, gut. Warum reagierst du jetzt so nervig? Ja, weil du mir auch nichts schenkst. Das ist ein sich immer wieder drehender Kreislauf. Der Henne-Ei-Problem. Ja, irgendjemand muss irgendwann anfangen. Ja, du. Du hast mir ein schönes Jahr geschenkt, Stefan, und das ist das Wichtigste. Wir können ja gleich einen Jahresrückblick gehen. Ich finde gut, wir machen einen Jahresrückblick erste Hälfte dieser Folge und zweite Hälfte wird eine Vorausschau. Erstmal müssen wir noch zurückblicken auf das Intro von dieser heutigen Folge. Da kam nämlich das Intro von Janik. Von wem? Von Clark. Die machen nicht nur saugute Apps, sondern die haben auch ein tolles Intro komponiert heute von Clark. Der perf Der perfekte Name. Vielen, vielen Dank an diese kleine New Turtles-Referenz. Vielen, vielen Dank, immer schön mit anzuhören. Ja, danke. Clark, so heißt in meinem Lieblings Weihnachtsfilm, ich bin auch ein Weihnachtsfieber, schöne Bescherung, der heißt Clark. Clark ist für immer in meinem Herzen als wunderschöner Name. Ist ein schöner Name. Vielen, vielen Dank natürlich auch nochmal an die ganzen Hörerintros, oder? Über das Jahr werden tolle Intros, die, welche haben dir am besten gefallen? Ja, das, was mir noch am präsentesten ist, ist das Ninja Turtles. Okay, ja, das war auch mein Liebsten. Das war, glaube ich, das Beste. Das hat auch mir sehr gut gefallen, muss ich sagen. Ja, seht mir nach, ich habe inzwischen ein sehr schlechtes Gedächtnis.
Du bist sehr löchrig geworden, ne?
Und weiss nicht mehr viel. Ich erinnere mich an kein Intro.
Bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno,
jato, bueno, bueno, bueno,
bueno, jato.
Das habe ich sehr gefeiert.
Das habe ich immer noch ein Ohrwurm von deinem ekligen Daten.
Alte Daten.
Ach ja, ich hasse das.
Die sind ja richtig alt.
Alte Daten. Ach Gott, ich hasse das. Die sind ja richtig alt. Alte Daten. Ich hasse das. Lassen mich nicht kalt. Das Intro war toll, ja, aber der Song war hideous. Hideous. Ich werde den rausbringen. Ich werde den 2025 rausbringen. Das glaube ich dir, da kann dich niemand hin. Big Data ist vorbei, die Daten sind alt, die Daten liegen in der Ecke, niemand interessiert sich mehr für die Daten.
Stell dir mal vor, diesen Wust an Daten, der erhoben wurde, Facebook, NSA, die haben alles abgehört, die haben alles getrackt, die haben alles rausgezogen, die Daten, die liegen irgendwo traurig rum, alle deine Messages, deine ganzen Emojis, deine ganzen widerlich schnitzigen, sexigen Nachrichten.
Das hasse ich am wenigsten an diesem Song. Ich hasse die Melodie, ich hasse die Vortragsweise. Warum ist der fünf Oktaven so hoch? Antidaten! Das ist alles diese Melodie, das Arrangement, alles daran ist scheiße. Der Text ist das Letzte, was ich kritisiere. Okay, ja gut. Auch furchtbar. Den Rest kann ich nicht verteidigen. Ich kann nur den Text verteidigen. Beim Rest kann ich nicht sagen, aber der Text geht wirklich tief, weil ich glaube, wir sind in der nächsten Epoche, nach Big Data kommt jetzt die große Verwahrlosung der Daten und wir müssen gucken, wohin damit. All die ganzen schwitzigen Sexting-Texte, die du geschrieben hast, die alle noch irgendwo liegen auf einem Server, jemand muss sich um die kümmern, jemand muss sie ausmisten, sortieren und das wird ein Riesenproblem. Am Ende werden die alle vergraben einfach. Ich glaube, ich könnte sehr gut, habe ich schon mal gesagt, Erotikgeschichten schreiben und deswegen jetzt für 2025 möchte ich meine erste Erotikgeschichte rausbringen. Wir haben ja für lange Zeit angekündigt und wir nehmen das ernst. Für Fantasy. Genau, wir haben ja vor langer Zeit gesagt, weil das Problem ist natürlich, wenn es heißt, Stefan Tietze veröffentlicht, Schmuddel, Ficky-Ficky-Roman, dann geht er natürlich über die Ladentheke wie warmes Brot, das ist ja klar. Deswegen wollten wir, weil jeder von uns gegenseitig gesagt hat, er ist der jeweils Erotischere, dabei bleibe ich auch noch, ich halte mich für erotischer als du. Und deswegen dachten wir, wir schreiben Erotikromane anonym unter schwitzigen Sex-Aliassen und veröffentlichen die auf solchen Fanfiction-Seiten. Und welche besser geklickt wird, gewinnt. Genau, gewinnt. Allerdings wollten wir natürlich, um das realistisch zu machen, da auch viel Zeit vergehen lassen zwischen Ankündigung und Durchführung, damit ihr nicht dann jede Woche refreshed, refreshed, ah, welcher könnte von Florentin Steffen sein. Also ich habe schon eine Idee für einen Titel. Ich glaube, es ist nicht so gut, dass ich das ja schon sage. Ja. Aber mein erster Gedanke war Airport Crush. Der Airport Crush. Aber bei Fantasy, ich dachte, das geht in die Richtung Fantasy. Fantasy? Nee. Du hast doch gerade gesagt Fantasy. Fantasy. Was ist Fantasy? Fantasy ist eingesprochen, ich habe es ja schon weitergedacht, als Businessmodell, du kennst mich, Zahlen, Optimierung, Excel-Tabellen, Daten, Neue Daten, Steuern. Jaja, du machst das wirklich, du bist ja ein Virtuose. Und zwar fand ich gut, Fantasy ist glaube ich, ja, jetzt setzt man sich natürlich in die Nesseln, ich setze mich mal komplett rein kurz. Ich bin vollkommen ratlos, weil ich bin sehr gespannt, in welche Richtung es geht, weil so eine Angekündigung. Ich spring hoch, du machst einen Hecht jetzt, Arschbombe in die Nesseln. Und dann so mit Bauchklatscher in die Nesseln richtet sich vor allem ein weibliches Publikum. Jetzt habe ich gesagt, krass, crazy, alle Blicke auf mich gerichtet. What, was hat er gerade gesagt? Aber es ist trotzdem Fantasy. Ich glaube, es heißt sogar Feminine, deswegen Fantasy. Ja, aber warum denn Tessie? Alle Fiction-Geschichten sind ja fantastisch erdacht. Nee, aber Fantasy ist ja irgendwie Herr der Ringe. Für dich ist das ein Genre, ja. Ja, Fantasy. Wenn du in den Buchladen gehst und da steht Fantasy, dann liest du da Narnia. Das ist ja aufgebracht, ey. Sag mal, ey. Als ob Wörter keine Bedeutung mehr hätten. Du schwitzt, du kratzt, alles juckt, du zettst. Alle Poren offen gerade, alle Poren offen. Die Haare. Alles offen gerade. Naja, ist egal. Jedenfalls, da wird eingelesen und es ist so erotische Hörbücher for them girls. So, und ich will da den Airport Crush reinschreiben, weil ich glaube, Airport Crush ist gerade irgendwie, was heißt gerade, aber so die letzten Jahre so ein Phänomen. Und ich glaube, da liegt sehr viel Spannung drin. Denn der Airport Crush, klassisch, ist das überhaupt ein Begriff? Ach, Port, ich habe immer Airport, Airport Crush. Ich dachte so, ah, sie hat die Airpods getragen. Und ich wollte auch ihre Airpods tragen. Airport Crush. Ah, okay, Flughafen, ja, Flughafenschwarm. Ja, nee, genau nicht. Klingt wie ein Horrorroman. So, und da geht's natürlich, und dann würde ich mich so sehr nah an so Maxton Hall und sowas orientieren, also so englische Namen, wie zum Beispiel Richard. Aber dann diese weibliche Perspektive. Der Blutdruck steigt schon. Genau. Und dann hast du da, und dann sass er gegenüber. Wir sassen am gleichen Gate, Richard. Er war mir bereits, warum ich den Namen kenne? Ja, ein kleiner Blick auf seinen Koffer. Wir haben uns, sind uns bereits bei der ... Unangenehme Protagonistenstimme, finde ich. Wir sind uns bereits beim Security-Check begegnet. Er war direkt vor mir. Und wie der Security-Mann ihn abgetastet hat. Und wie heisst du? Kylie. Kylie. Oder so. Kylie Richard. Genau. Und die Idee ist, dass sie Richard oder so sieht, Crush entwickelt und natürlich, deswegen mag ich dieses Konzept Airport Crush auch so sehr, dieses Vergängliche. Genau, man hat nicht viel Zeit. Fliegen wir ans gleiche Ziel, wir sind in einer Zwischenwelt, so einem Traum. Der ist kurz, ist wie nicht real. Gleich wachen wir auf und sind auf verschiedenen Orten. Vielleicht ist eine der beiden ja gebunden auf irgendeine Art. Und man sagt, es zählt nicht, wenn es über der Wolkendecke ist. Dann sind die erdlichen Gesetze gelten nicht. Dann ist so die Frage, wo haben sie dann, wo kommen sie sich näher und wie. Da liegt viel Spannung drin das würde ich gerne schreiben und das ist meine Idee für 2025 mein Debüt Erotikroman naja, da gab es ja schon was oder die Glocken von Dublin gab es ja das ist kein Erotik Thriller das wurde dann von Foyotone draufgepresst wenn du in den normalen Buchladen gehst, du findest es in der Erotikabteilung. Übrigens ist lustig, das ist mir jetzt jetzt, wir verlassen mal kurz die Meta-Ebene und kurz, der echte Stefan spricht kurz. Okay. Ich finde das so faszinierend, was für ein Ego in der Literaturwelt herrscht. Weil da gab es jetzt so zwei Beispiele, zum einen ist ja dieser Mann, der nicht gewonnen hat, den Deutschen Buchpreis, hat das mitbekommen, der dann ausgeflippt ist. Ehrlich gesagt, ich bin nicht so tief. Ich auch nicht. Du bist ja mittlerweile in der Autorenbranche. Ach komm, nein. Aber der ist so, da ist jemand dann, der wollte dann unbedingt gewinnen und der ist dann ausgeflippt, weil er nicht gewonnen hat und ist im Publikum. Und ich finde das so, in so einer Welt, in der wir ja gerade sind, wo alle so sich so mega humble geben, alle immer schon die Außenwirkung mitdenken, bei Instagram wird kein hottest Bild von sich gepostet, nur mit so neun coolen Gags unten, die das so abrunden, damit so ein, also es sind immer schon die Aussensicht mitgedacht, das Sendebewusstsein ist da, und der Typ ist einfach ausgeführt, weil er nicht gewonnen hat, hat die Jüre beleidigt und den Raum verlassen. Ich will aber! Das fand ich so geil, das fand ich so fucking lustig. Und dann eine Schriftstellerin wurde gar nicht erst nominiert und hat dann auch online so eine Hetzkampagne, also hat sich beschwert darüber. Und ich finde das so geil, dass da so ein Ego ist. Ja, technisch gesehen wurdest du ja auch nicht nominiert für den Buchpreis, für Glocken in Dublin hat's ja ... Ja, ich sag ja, weil von außen eine Schmutzkampagne, auch von dir, diese geckige Schmutzkampagne, Erotik, billig, da wird so billig auf die niedrigsten Triebe angespielt und so, und da wurde da schnell so ein Erotik-Label draufgeklatscht. Glocken in Dublin war für mich ... Hast du das Cover mal gesehen? Aber das habe ich ja nicht gemalt, das Cover. Ja gut, aber es geht in eine sehr direkte Richtung. Ja, aber wieso denn nicht? Was sagen sie auch so schlimm? Die weibliche Brust ist ja erst mal in seiner anatomischen Darstellung jetzt nichts Wildes, aber es ist natürlich auch diese kleinen Glöckchen, die das dann halt so billig bedecken, nur Glocken in Dublin, das ist natürlich die Doppeldeutung, also das ist natürlich schon direkt. Der Titel, der Verlag hat den Titel draufgepresst und rückblickend fühle ich mich da wirklich auch hintergangen. Klar, ich will nicht sagen, dass es vielleicht die Verkaufszahlen, den Verkaufszahlen zuträglich war. Allerdings, ja. Bestseller. Bestseller. Auch in drei Sprachen übersetzt. Ja. Ins Polnische. Die Bratatschadalas. Ins Portugiesische. Semranon Sovajdo. Und ins Zwedische. Szentete Patetten. Patetten. Die sind ja oft sehr direkt in ihrer Sprache, ne? Aber ich finde, du hast da wirklich deine feinsinnige Erotik bewiesen, auf jeden Fall. Und ich bin gespannt auf den Airport Crush. Ich finde es interessant, weil ich hatte auch mir überlegt, was macht man als Erotikroman. Ich habe aber das Fantasy wörtlicher genommen und habe an Fantasy gedacht. Und dachte, ich gehe in eine etwas andere Richtung mit die Ritter der Fickrunde.
Genau, wenn mir ein besseres Beispiel einfällt, kurz dazu Fantasy, Fantasie, du kannst eine Sexfantasie haben. Ach so, ich dachte eher so Merlin und ... Also die Ritter der Fickrunde? Genau. Und es geht um eine Runde strammer Rittersleute, die ausziehen um, naja, so, das ist halt so die Ausgangssituation. Und mehr weiß ich jetzt auch noch nicht genau, in welche Richtung das geht, aber ich finde der Anfang ist schon mal stark. Ritter der Fickrunde. Genau. Es basiert lose auf der Artus-Saga. Habe ich mir schon fast gedacht. Aber nur, dass kein Schwert aus dem Stein gezogen wird. Richtig, richtig. Das als kleiner Spoiler. Aber ich habe mich da inspirieren lassen, auch von der ursprünglichen Sage und keine Sorge, Lanze wird auftauchen. Das sei mal der Lanze, der strammen Lanze. Ja, also da macht euch bitte keine Sorgen. Das sind öffentliche Releases. Wir werden das komplett anonym droppen. Ich werde der Airport Crush komplett anonym droppen. Naja, du hast ja einen anderen Titel, ich habe ja auch einen anderen Titel. Also das sind ja nur die Übertitel für die Reihen. Nee, ich finde der Titel ist tatsächlich wichtig, dass das der ist. Ach, das ist der Titel? Naja, ja, jetzt eben nicht mehr, aber es ist eigentlich, glaube ich, es ist schon wichtig, dass du mit dem Titel schon eine gewisse Erwartungshaltung wächst. Und ich glaube, der Airport Crush, auch das ist Konzept. Ich glaube, man muss sich auch an Frauen richten, weil ich glaube, Sexgeschichten werden von Frauen gelesen. Ja, aber wo genau richtest du mit, aber kann man da nicht ein Wortspiel machen mit Crash? Der Crush-Crash oder so? Der Airport-Crash. Der Crush. Börsen-Crush. Aber der Börsen-Crush. Ja, klar, natürlich, du kommst so neu in eine Firma, musst dich da zurechtfinden, irgendwie was da los ist, All Nighter, du bist die ganze Nacht im Büro, dann kannst du noch hier übernachten oder so. Börsen-Crush All-Nighter mit Jim aus der Buchhaltung.
So, guckt mal.
Also da glaube ich sind jetzt einige Blusen aufgegangen
unter unseren Hörern.
Ich glaube, da kann man sich einiges drunter vorstellen.
Finde ich schon immer gut.
Ich dachte natürlich eher, als du gesagt hast, Airport,
dachte ich so einsame Insel. So, man crasht so auf einer einsamen Insel. Alle sind tot, überall Leichen, überall Kadaver, Blut, blutige Gliedmasse und überlebt haben nur Keith und Caitlin. Das Geschwisterpart. Leider, leider. So, aber nee, das ist ja auch erotisch, weil erstmal, also jedes andere Paar würde ja relativ bald sagen, okay, schnackseln, los geht's, aber die haben noch diese Geschwisterhürde drin. Und die ganzen Leichen, die du gerade drei Minuten geschrieben hast. Genau, es gibt viele Kadaver, die natürlich Stück für Stück verfaulen, ineinander übergehen. Also ich dachte, die schmelzen so in der heißen Karibiksonne. Ja, das ist nicht so hot, also das ist nicht so erotisch, anregend. Die schauen immer wieder rein und diese Leichen, die werden immer mehr zu einer gelehrtartigen Masse. Und du kannst gar nicht mehr Körper von Körper unterscheiden, ist natürlich alles metaphorisch für Sex, sondern die Körper verschmilzen miteinander und irgendwann sagt Keith diesen Satz ich weiß nicht mehr, wo ein Körper aufhört und der andere anfängt. So, und dann Caitlin schaut ihn so an mit so einem Redest du noch über die Kadaver? Und Keith sagt, ja, ja, ja. So, und um jegliche Subtilität wegzunehmen. Das ist für mich erotisch.
Nimmst du Notes an, kann ich was sagen?
Nein, ich nehme keine Notes mehr an.
Erotisch ist für mich, alles liegt auf dem Tisch.
Eine Note, die ich hätte an deinem Schreibstil, wäre
lass doch mal Dinge unausgesprochen.
Ja, aber worüber soll ich denn schreiben?
Worüber soll ich denn schreiben?
Weißt du, ich will ja Dinge unausgesprochen lassen,
aber dann ist die Seite halt leer.
So, das ist ja mein Grundproblem.
Dein Grundproblem ist, dass du so sehr viel Nonnen, alles aussprichst. Ja, weil die kriegen den Motor nicht aus. Das ist nämlich das Ding, das Flugzeug ist abgestürzt, aber der Motor ist noch an. Ja. So, und der Propeller dreht sich die ganze Zeit. Eine Metapher dafür, dass man im Hamsterrad ist, im Hamsterrad gefangen ist. Eine Metapher dafür, dass natürlich diese unstillbare Gier nach Körperlichkeit nicht versiegt. Ja, aber das steht ja in dem Buch. Du schreibst ja dann eine Fußnote, das ist eine Metapher dafür. Ja, Keith sagt das. Ja, aber das muss er ja nicht ansprechen, so redet ja auch niemand. Niemand sagt etwas, was um einen herum passiert, eine Metapher ist für das, was passiert. Die sind auf der Insel und die spüren natürlich irgendwann diese körperliche Anziehungskraft. Ja, die müssen sich waschen, dann heißt es so, dreht man sich weg oder nicht, wir sind ja Geschwister und so, und dann die Körper, man nimmt sie anders wahr und man hat sich vielleicht auch schon lange nicht mehr gesehen, Erinnerungen aus der Kindheit und so weiter und so weiter. und man spürt diese aufkommende Lust, hofft aber, dass sie versiegt.
Und dafür steht dieser Motor, dass man denkt, er muss ja irgendwann aufhören zu drehen. Das ist ja alleswörtliche Rede.
Ja, genau. Und ich meine, das nimmt halt die Erotik weg, weil wenn Keith literally sagt, ja, man spürt ja schon, dass da was ist, aber man muss mal gucken, weil das ist alles so, das nimmt ja die jegliche Spannung weg, weil er sagt das ja alles. Genau, und dann sagen die, schauen wir heute mal, ob der Problem, weil die gehen natürlich weit weg, derller ist laut, deswegen gehen die auf die andere Seite der Insel, um zu schlafen. Und dann hast du für dich fünf Seiten lang da stehen.
Beide denken natürlich bei dem Geräusch
an was ganz anderes.
Ja, sie sagen das ja auch.
Ich denke gerade an was anderes.
So, aber verstehst du, du musst dem Leser ja auch
sagen, was er denken soll.
Weiß ich halt nicht. Auch der Weg, und du kannst, was ich auch noch sagen wollte,
zweite Note, du kannst ja schneiden.
Wenn sie beschliessen, auf die andere Seite der Insel
zu gehen, mit dir
geht man dann den ganzen Weg in Echtzeit
mit denen mit. Train of thought nennt man das.
Ja, und die reden halt die ganze Zeit belanglosen
Kram, was man halt machen würde, wenn man kurz
woanders hingeht, um in Ruhe zu reden.
Hast du eine Ahnung, wie viele Seiten so ein fucking
Buch hat? Es geht.
Ich hab die Geschichte geschrieben, es waren zweieinhalb
Seiten. So, und dann
hat mein Lektor gesagt, Herr Will, das kann ich so nicht veröffentlicht, das ist kein Pixie-Buch. Er hat gesagt, ne, das ist aber so, auch von dem Inhalt. Ist das ein Pixie-Buch? Ah, geil! Ein Pixie-Buch. Wie krieg ich das noch rein? Wie? Wie krieg ich das noch rein? Kann Keith die finden? Genau, da ist dann so die Leiche von so einem kleinen Kind und dann wollen die den Rucksack gucken, ob da noch was zu trinken drin ist, weil die haben Durst und dann finden die so ein Pixie-Buch und er so, ja wohl eher. So, schauen wir am Ende einfach, wessen Geschichte mehr Herzen bekommt oder mehr Flammen-Emojis oder was auch immer, wie das auf diesen Websites funktioniert. Da müssen wir nicht wissen, haben wir keine Ahnung, vor allem müssen wir das mal einlesen. Ich freue mich da sehr drauf. Das ist 2025 das große Projekt. Wird das ein schwitziges Jahr? Es wird ein schwitziges Jahr, glaube ich, oder? Schwitzig? Also schwitzig im Sinne von Lüstern, erotisch. Ach so, schwitzig auch da, das falsche, das ist immer so haarscharf auch das falsche Wort bei dir in den Texten. Findest du Schweiss nicht? Doch, aber jetzt ist es nicht das Erste, was mir einfällt, wenn man sagt, es ist ein aufregendes Ja im sexuellen Sinne. Da würde ich nicht sagen, es ist ein schwitziges Ja. Ja, schwitzig heißt ja auch sehr angestrengt, also Anstrengung. Genau, anstrengendes Jahr. Ja.
Nee, auch nicht so gut.
Aber 25 ist schon geil, oder?
25, also als Zahl.
Es hat so was von einem Viertel.
Ich denke mir immer so, oh krass, schon ein Viertel.
Aber eigentlich ist es Viertel von 8100, so.
Was jetzt auch nicht so spektakulär ist, aber ich denke immer so. Aber 25 ist ja das Viertel von einer Hundert.
Genau.
Und auf 2100 hingegen freue ich mich schon sehr. Ich denke auch immer so, wow, schon Viertel, so Viertel meines Lebens. So, ja. 2100 werde ich nicht mehr erleben. Vermutlich. Du sowieso nicht. Ja, also ich kämpfe gerade mit, ich kämpfe mit 2040. Nein, weil du älter bist als ich. Weil, ich sag mal so, es ist aktuell, wir sind ja gläsende Podcast, es ist 14 Uhr und ich habe, glaube ich, schon acht Ballisto gegessen. Und in einer Packung sind sechs Stück. Also könnt ihr euch ja selber ausrechnen, was das für ein Vormittag war. Fantastischer? Ein richtig leckerer. Äh, welche Ballisto? Farbe? Grün, und ich denke mir jedes Mal, Leute, bietet doch unterschiedliche Farben in einer Packung an. Wo sind eigentlich, sorry, das ist mir 2024, wir können ja gleich noch zum Jahresreplikum, mir abhandengegangen, der Verlust des Jahres. Und zwar, wo sind die kleinen Ritter Sport? Die kleinen zweimal zwei Rittersport, die sind mir komplett abhandengekommen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es an mir liegt, aber ich habe kein einziges davon gegessen. Normalerweise immer so im 20er, 30er Bereich. Neulich, ich bin ja so ein Opfer, habe ich dann gedacht, weil ich war abends, es war Samstagabend und ich hatte so richtig Bock auf Dubai-Schokolade. Ja, ich bin einer von denen. Nee, das war ja der Trend. Weil es gibt einen Laden bei mir um die Ecke, das ist so eine ganz süße, kleine, private, so eine ältere Frau hat diesen Laden, der läuft nicht so gut. Und das ist so ein Patisserie-Laden in Köln. Und der war dann irgendwie auch in der Zeitung und lief nicht so gut und so. Und deswegen, seitdem gehe ich da immer hin. Was ist denn das für eine komische Artikel? Seitdem gehe ich da immer hin. Ja, oh Gott. Und die hatten dann diesen Trend. Ich habe da noch nichts Problem. Doch wir hatten, irgendwer hatte mal Backstage zu uns nach einer Improv-Show.
Ja, Gunnar Krupp.
Gunnar Krupp, wirklich, der kam von Borkum mit
Dubai-Schokolade zu uns.
Hat uns das gezeigt. Wir haben es probiert zum ersten Mal
und es ist schon sau lecker. Weil ich mag,
ich liebe Pistazien, ich liebe Schokolade
und ich liebe diese Engelshaar-Gedöns kam da drin.
Super lecker, sondern es wurde diesen Riesen-Hype
und ich bin wirklich fucking anfällig
für sowas und wenn man darüber redet,
läuft man das Wasser im Mund zu haben, ich will das haben.
Und dann, sie hat das selber gebacken,
dann im Laden, dann habe ich das mitgenommen,
es war so unglaublich lecker,
dann hatte der Laden aber zu und ich wollte unbedingt Dubai-Schokolade
haben, ich mag das alles nicht,
dass da alle drüber reden gerade,
dass es so heisst, dass es Dubai-Schokolade heisst,
alles daran finde ich kacke und dann habe ich mich so gehasst, wie ich dann so durch Köln wandel, von Supermarkt zu Supermarkt, um zu gucken, wer den hat und so. Und hatte natürlich niemand diese Scheisse. Und ich kam mir vor wie so ein TikTok-Opfer. Und dann war ich vor dem Schokoladenregal und dann habe ich mir so die alten, geilen Schokoladen, die meine Mom mir damals immer zu Weihnachten zum Beispiel, und so besonderen Anlässen
habe ich die bekommen. Zum Beispiel
Theodora. Das ist so,
kennst du das, diesen sechseckigen,
so gelben, hellgelben
Kasten. Sechseckig. Sechseckig
oder achteckig sogar. Ja. Achteckig
glaube ich. So ein Kasten und da sind
so super
häufig eingepackt so kleine Rechtecke
drin und so dünner Schokolade. Oh ja. Die ist so sehr speziell. Ich habe die geliebt, die ist richtig lecker. Rechtecke in sechs Ecken, genau. Achtecke. Rechtecke in acht Ecken. Genau, viereckige Rechtecke in einen achteckigen Brustgasten. Ja, ja, ja. Und die sind verpackt mit dieser hellgelben Folie und da drin ist noch eine Silberfolie. Ja. Und darin sind die Schokoladen. Ja, ja,aden. Also man braucht wirklich 30 Minuten, bis man dann drin ist, aber dann lohnt es sich. Der Weg ist das Ziel. Die und Katzenzungen. Katzenzungen mit dieser outdated Verpackung, mit den Katzen drauf. Mit diesen kleinen Katzen, die alle schon tot sind. Genau, mausetot. Mausoletto tot, alle ihre Nachbarn tot. Diese Familienlinie ist ausgerottet, diese Katzen sind hinüber. Und zwei von denen mit Sicherheit viel zu früh. So, die sind aber gekauft, so und dann war da noch irgendwie so Mozartkugeln, die hatten dann auch noch Pistazie drin, da habe ich ein bisschen Pistazie, ein bisschen Crunch, Mozartkugeln gekauft, die drei gekauft, bin zur Kasse gegangen, an der Kasse, Dinge aufs Kassenband gelegt, an der Kasse oben Dubai-Schokolade. Ich so, oh nein, jetzt kann ich ja nicht meinen ganzen Einkauf, lag schon am Backeband. Deine ganze Familiengeschichte, Nostalgie, Kindheit. Ich kann jetzt nicht diese drei Sachen nehmen und wegwerfen und dann oben einfach mit Dubai-Schokolade, habe ich mir oben noch zwei dazugeholt. So hatte ich einen Haufen Schokolade. Und es war so Samstagabend, es war komplett voll in diesem Edeka. Und dann meinte der Typ so zu mir, oh, Sie haben sich aber eine ganz tolle Auswahl besorgt. Und ich dachte mir so, halt dein Maul, halt dein Maul, halt dein verkacktes Maul. Arschloch. Ihr macht den Leuten den kompletten Tag kaputt. Und nicht so, ja, man muss ja mal alles testen.
Das war das Lustigste, was mir eingefallen ist.
Ganz schrecklich, ich war ja auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt in Essen und hab mir da natürlich, ich liebe ja Schaumwaffeln, diese Schaumwaffeleimer, und die gibt's immer so an Weihnachtsmärkten.
Und dann bin ich da hingegangen und hab mir Schaumwaffeln gekauft und dachte mir schon viel zu viel, Schaumwaffeln, die länglichen, die Eistüten, die quadratischen, so.
Und dann bin ich später am Tag nochmal hingegangen, weil ich noch mehr Schaumwaffeln wollte. Und dann so, ah, sie habe ich ja heute schon gesehen. Ja, ich kaufe noch mal Schaumwaffeln im Abstand von drei Stunden, kaufe ich Schaumwaffeln im Kalorienwert von 3.500. Hast du gesagt, ich komme in drei Stunden auch noch mal. Furchtbar. Und dann habe ich diese drei Schokoladen, also Fiodora, Katzenzungen, Mozartkugeln, zweimal Oberschokolade. Wie viel habe ich gezahlt? 25 Euro? Sechsundfünfzig Euro. Und dann habe ich gedacht, habt ihr einen kompletten Schaden. Das war so schlimm für mich. Was für ein Opfer ich bin. Du hast dich komplett ausdribbeln lassen. Selbsthass. Du hast wirklich Trend und dann aber Antitrend und dann wolltest du doch noch vom Trend und hast du wegen dem Trend, konntest du die anderen Sachen nicht weglesen. Du hast dich so komplett in dich eingewickelt. Der große und dann 56 und dann auch keine Tasche dabei gehabt, weil ich nur diese Dubai-Schokolade wollte, dann bin ich dann so super lange mit diesem super kalt und dann bin ich so in Jogginghose mit diesem Stapel Schokolade. Aber das war alles so, da war wirklich schlimm selbst aus. Aber das ist auch einer meiner Vorsätze für 25, wir können ja gleich noch zu den Vorsätzen kommen. Genau, und zum Rückblick auch noch kommen. Wir können auch gleich später noch machen. Und zwar, mein Vorsatz ist, keine Angst vor Trends. Man ist jung und man rennt jedem Trend hinterher. Man ist nicht mehr so jung. Dann wird man älter und sagt, Trends, peinlich, das machen alle anderen, alle anderen Rennen her. Und man hat so diese Indie-Phase, so ich bin anders als alle anderen, genauso peinlich. Und jetzt kommt Phase drei, fuck it, wenn ich es cool finde, mache ich den Trend mit. Warum denn nicht Überschokolade essen, wenn ich Bock drauf habe? Ich bin jetzt in Phase drei, wo ich sage, scheiß drauf, so übernervig, dass gerade alle Raw-Dogging sagen, so what, mir egal, sei ich auch Raw-Dogging oder nicht, völlig egal, alles was, wenn ich Bock drauf habe, mache ich es, wenn ich nicht, alles hinter mir lassen, Phase drei, Freiheit, also Phase drei, Synthese, Freiheit einfach, komplett, mir völlig egal. Ja, ich finde Begeisterungsfähigkeit immer besser als so ein zynischer Blick auf die Trends. Weg aus der Metaperspektive hinzu was wollt ihr, lebt dein fucking Leben, wie du willst. Ich hatte letztens war ich im Supermarkt und dann kam die Durchsage, jetzt der Joghurt mit der Ecke Vanillekipferl mit leckeren Vanillekipferlstücken und herrlichem Lebkuchen. Und Florian, schmeißt die Arme in den Lüffel ruf. Ich schmeiss meinen Korb auf den Boden, schmeiss alles über mich hinweg, zieh die Jacke aus. Und dann sagt jemand so, Sir, Sir, die Eier, die Eier, was machen Sie? Egal, die Eier sind 2024, die Eier sind nicht mehr ich. Dann hast du die Hose ausgezogen. Und ich bin zum Kühlregal gegangen und hab mir genau diesen Joghurt mit der Ecke geholt und habe ihn gekauft. Und ich weiß genau, dass viele da draußen, peinlich, werbunganfällig, scheiß drauf. Wenn die Werbung sagt, wenn ich Bock habe, weil die Werbung es mir sagt, habe ich trotzdem Bock drauf und hol es mir. War das peinlich, war das dumm, wurde ich manipuliert? Ja! Trotzdem hatte ich einen mittelmässigen Joghurt für zu viel Geld zu Hause, ja! So, hatte ich zu Hause und ich habe mich dafür nicht geschämt. Ich weiss, dass andere Florentins gesagt hätten, ich hätte jetzt schon echt Lust auf den, aber nein, ich kaufe mir jetzt bewussten was anderes. Ich kaufe mir jetzt bewussten Milchreis, weil ich will nicht auf die Wärme reinfallen. Diese Schwäche, weil man nicht mehr bereit ist, sich die Energie aufzubringen, sich dagegen zu wehren. Ja. Naja, ich habe dann auch gekauft, bin nach Hause, habe mir die reingedonnert und mir war schlecht. Und dann habe ich gesagt, gut, also wenn ich noch bei meiner Mom leben würde, würde mir das nicht passieren. Dann dürfte ich nicht mehr so spät raus. Also das Kind. Dann hätte ich nicht so viel Taschengeld. Das Kind. Ich könnte mir das nicht leisten. Ich dürfte nicht mehr raus für Schokolade. Sie würde sagen, sie macht so einen kompletten Schaden. Und ich dürre auch nicht so viel Essen. Und dann will ich alles gemacht, was Freiheit ja sagt. Naja. Süßigkeiten kann man auch mal sagen. Ich esse ja viel Süßigkeiten, aber man isst sie wahrscheinlich auch nur, um diesem Gefühl aus der Kindheit hinterher zu jagen, dass es was Besonderes war. Eine meiner schönsten Erinnerungen, wahrscheinlich meines gesamten Lebens, ist, ich hatte ja ein Kinderzimmer im Keller. Das heißt, ich hatte einen eigenen Ausgang. Das heißt, ich konnte rein theoretisch rein und raus, wann immer ich will, ohne dass meine Ältesten mitbekommen. Habe ich das jemals genutzt, um auf eine heisse Party zu gehen? Nein. Aber an diesem einen Abend, ich weiß noch, ich habe... Du meinst auf eine schwitzige Party. Richtig, nein. An diesem Abend habe ich Harry Potter gelesen, auf Englisch, Band sechs oder sieben, glaube ich. Und mitten in der Nacht, es war halb sieben. Wird es noch wichtig, dass es auf Englisch gelesen ist? Nee, ich will es nur zeitlich einordnen, damit Leute ungefähr wissen, was es ist. Nee, du willst brag, dass es auf Englisch gelesen ist. Nee, ich habe es auf Englisch, The Philosopher's Stone. Ah, nicht The Chaucer? The Half-Blood Prince. Und dann weiss ich noch, dachte ich mir, Alter, jetzt ein Colorado. Aber es ist halb sieben. Ein Colorado? Und dann bin ich nachts, also halb sieben, bin ich rausgeschlichen zum Aldi, hab mir ein Colorado gekauft. Wie, hör auf das zu sagen. Ich bin zurück, hab mich wieder in meinen Sessel mir nicht? Weitergelegt und Colorado genascht. Send dich noch?
Und das war ein schönes Gefühl in meines Lebens.
Es war wirklich so, okay, das dauert jetzt eine halbe Stunde,
zu Aldi Einkauf zurück.
Währenddessen meine Eltern wussten nicht,
dass ich das Haus verlassen hatte.
Ist denen auch scheißegal, weil ich war 16.
Aber trotzdem war dieses Gefühl,
dass ich sneke jetzt alleine raus,
hole mir was. Ich glaube, deswegen fresse ich auch so viele Süssigkeiten mich rein,
weil ich es mit diesem verbotenen Gefühl
und mit diesem, ah, das ist was Besonderes.
Aber Aber trotzdem war dieses Gefühl des, ich sneake jetzt alleine raus, hol mir was. Ich glaube, deswegen fresse ich auch so viele Süßigkeiten mich rein, weil ich es mit diesem verbotenen Gefühl und mit diesem, ah, das ist was Besonderes. Aber wenn du halt an acht Ballist zu dir reinschnabbelst, ohne dass dich jemand auffällt, ist auch nicht mehr das Gleiche. Idee, ich habe einen Pitch, und zwar möchte ich gerne die Geschichte, die du gerade erzählt hast, und das, was in der Geschichte vorkam, Harry Potter, kombinieren zu einer neuen Idee, Startup-Idee. Und zwar, über der Tür, über der Haustür ist ein großer Monitor und alle Kinder, kleine Kinder in dem Fall, haben AirTag an sich dran. Wir reden von kleinen Kindern, wo man wissen sollte, wo die sind. Und dann, weil die Weasleys haben ja diese große Uhr, die zeigt, wo Leute sind. Ja. man nach Hause kommt, dann schlägt die Uhr um. Der Fred-and-George-Schalter geht dann um auf zu Hause. Schule sind manche dann zu Hause. Datenschutztechnisch auch fragwürdig. Ja, aber Zauberei. Und deswegen fände ich doch geil, so ein Bildschirm mit so einer Karte von der Stadt. Ja. Und dann sieht man da, wo ist der Ehemann, wo ist die Ehefrau, wo sind die Kids gerade und dann abends sind die alle zu Hause und dann ist da einer mal im Urlaub und man sieht, ah krass, und dann geht die Weltkarte auf und dann sieht man, ah, Franco ist hier hinten. Du willst quasi für deine eigene Familie so einen Bildschirm, so eine Art Bilderrahmen an der Wand, wo du immer siehst, wo alle aus der Familie gerade sind. Einfach gar nicht jetzt als Überwachungsinstrument. Nein. Das war ja komisch ausgeschrieben. Es kann ja so grob sein. Süß, für uns alle. Es kann ja die Weltkarte sein. Zum Beispiel? Ziemlich, wie sind die Weltkarte.arte. So dass man nicht präzis sieht und sind einfach alle immer genau auf einem Punkt. Nee, es ist die Stadt, es ist genau die Straße. Es ist genau die Hausnummern. Aber das ist ja schon Überwachung, so dann sehe ich ja irgendwie, oh, Lisa ist gar nicht in der Schule. Wo ist sie denn? An der alten Mühle. Ah, was macht sie denn da? Fischen. Sie hat jetzt Ronja Räubertochter gelesen und fängt jetzt. Wem ficht sie denn da jetzt? Das weiß ich nicht. Zoomen wir mal rein. Wie, wir zoomen rein. Wir haben Satelliten im All. Du hast einen Satelliten im All? Die Firma hat dann auch Satelliten im All. Ja, mit Jochen. Ah, aus der 7b. Ja. Okay, zoomen wir rein. Zoomen wir rein. Ja, wir zoomen, okay, ja, wir zoomen wir rein. Okay, was machen sie da? Okay, Sie haben einen Fisch, einen Fisch in der Hand, der zappelt, der zappelt, der zappelt, der zappelt, wo ist die Hand von Jochen, wo ist die Hand von Jochen, ich brauche mehr Bilder, ich brauche das Team, ich brauche ein Team auf dem Dach, Team auf dem Dach auf der Mühle.
Alles klar, ausgerückt, Jochen schlägt auf den Fisch, der Fisch ist tot, Fisch ist down, Körperkontakt zu meiner Tochter, Fisch ist down, Hand auf Schulter, Hand auf Schulter. Hand auf Schulter. Schießen, schießen, schießen. Sie nähern sich. Sie nähern sich. Sie nähern sich. Ausgeführt, ausgeführt. Jochen down, Jochen down, Jochen down, Jochen down, Jochen down. Also ich finde es eine super süße Idee. Ja, okay, das ist eine süße Idee für zu Hause. Ja, finde ich echt, kann man mal auch nutzen, ja. Finde ich richtig süss. Echt eine schöne Sache. Ja, das finde ich schön. Ich habe eine Band gesehen,
ich war gestern am Konzert, ganz, ganz toll.
Eine alte deutsche
Band. Die Prinzen?
Ich sage nicht, wer es ist, kann ich nicht sagen.
Sind es die Prinzen?
Flodin, ich habe dich beim ersten Mal gehört,
es sind nicht die Prinzen.
Aha.
Okay, mehr Fragen? Enthält die Band einen Artikel? Nein. So. Okay. Enthält die Band einen Thronfolger? Nein. Aha. Wie viele Bands? Fuck. Ja, dann stehe ich auf dem Schlauch. Ja, das glaube ich. Also jedenfalls und diese Band, die da habe ich danach dann gegoogelt, weil ich dachte die ganze Zeit, das ist die Band, das ist die Band, die ich die Band des Jahres, die Band des Jahres? Nein, die Band, die ich unter dem Namen kenne, die damals diese krassen Lieder gemacht haben, war mega emotional, weil vor mir war so ein Junge mit seinem Opa da und da haben die sich so im Arm gehabt und ich habe fast geheult, weil ich fand das so schön, das war so generationenübergreifend, haben die diese alte Band gesehen und irgendwie war der Sohn ... Wie im Arm, so umarmt? Der hat sich so umarmt, sein Opa so von hinten so auf die Schulter, es war richtig, richtig süss. Und das war, weil er sich das gesamte Konzert. Nein, nein, nur bei einem so einem Highlight-Song. Und ich fand das so schön und rührend und so, Generationen kamen zusammen, ältere Frauen haben geschunkelt, das war schön, da war für alle was dabei.
So, dann habe ich, dann war ich emotional berührt, weil diese Band auch schon so lange existiert, die haben nächstes Jahr eigentlich 50-Jähriges Jubiläum. Es sind die Prinzen, es sind die Prinzen. Keine Thronfolger. Gehe ich danach ins World Wide Web und sehe, keiner von denen, ich übertreibe, aber keiner von denen war in der Ursprungsbesetzung, weil die sind alle schon tot, alle tot, alle mausetot, Ursprungsbesetzung weg. Und die Leute, die gestern auf der Bühne waren, waren Randos. Ich habe mich so betrogen gefühlt in die Emotion und dachte mir, die kriegst du nicht mehr zurück. Wer war denn dann dieser Junge, der vor mir seinen Opa umarmt, als Dankeschön und was für eine rührende, ich dachte mir, ja, wenn das die alte Band ist, in der er hat die früher gehört und er hört die jetzt und dann liegen sie alle in den Arm und what the fuck, wie schön ist das denn? Aber sorry, das ist Opa, der auch bei FIFA denkt, er schaut die Weltmeisterschaft so, dem kannst du alles zeigen und er denkt, er ist gerade beim Prinzenkonzert. Das stimmt schon, nicht die Prinzenkonzerte. Und dann habe ich aber gedacht,
das gibt's, ich wurde betrogen, meine Emotionen,
ich fühle mich wahnsinnig benutzt und
weggeworfen. Also du würdest sagen, die Emotionen,
das war alles nur geklaut?
Ja, das würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Was ist deine Lieblingsband?
Aktuell tatsächlich
Glass Beams.
Das ist ironischerweise wieder
eine Band, die mit
Vielen Dank. Was ist deine Lieblingsband? Aktuell tatsächlich Glass Beams. Das ist ironischerweise wieder eine Band, die mit Glass anfängt. Das ist die nächste im Alphabet. Ja, tatsächlich. Nach Glass Animals kommt Glass Beams. Das ist die nächste im Alphabet. Ich bin einfach ein sehr geordneter, excelorientierter Mensch und ich habe mir gesagt, gib mir mal alle Bands eine Liste und die mache ich jetzt,
arbeite ich jetzt durch. Das heißt,
ich freue mich noch auf die Prinzen, die stehen noch vor mir.
Als nächstes kommt vielleicht Green Day.
Wieso, die Prinzen ist danach,
also es ist nicht nach Artikeln. Ja, auf die freue ich mich noch,
genau. Warum? Nee, Prinzen,
die, na klar, Prinzen, die, sonst hast du ja ewig viel D,
da kommst du dein Leben lang nicht durch. Nee,
Glassbeams bin ich jetzt, ich mag einfach Glas.
Ich wollte mir ein Buch kaufen vom Künstler
Willem de Kooning.
Und ich hab's nicht gefunden, unter
W, nicht unter
D und nicht unter K.
Und ich dachte mir, das gibt's doch nicht, es ist jetzt
nicht der originellste Künstler.
The Willem de Kooning.
Wo würdest du Willem de Kooning?
Das ist immer so dieses Ludwig van Beethoven-Ding, dieses L, V-B-Di. Viel Spaß bei Ludwig Mies van der Rohe. Aber sag mal, wo würdest du Willem de Kooning einordnen, D oder K? D schon, oder? Ich glaube, es gibt nicht so viele. Also es kommt darauf an, wenn du jetzt wirklich in einem Land bist, wo ihr Jahr Zweite so heißt, dann nicht, aber wenn das jetzt so eine internationale Datenbank ist, würde ich schon bei
de, de, glaube ich so,
da weißt du ja nicht, was der Ding davon soll,
deswegen.
Schwierig, aber ist schwierig, Namen,
ich bin ja eh für eine Generalüberholung, dass du einfach
wirklich mal sagst, alle Namen auf dem Tisch,
welche können weg, welche sollen neu dazu,
mal so ein bisschen Variants reinbringen. Sind Nachnamen nicht
überholt, generell? Nachnamen
nerven mich. Ich bin eh für Nicknames. So, das ist dieses komplette Namenskonstrukt, weil es ist immer so nervig mit, ja, wer übernimmt den Nachnamen bei der Ehe, das ist alles so altmursch und alles so angestaubt und da schaue ich mit Liebe irgendwie auch zum Beispiel in den E-Sport, wo einfach jeder seinen Nickname hat. Du heisst halt einfach, jeder hat halt einen anderen Namen, du heisst halt No-T, Boxi, der Rizzler, Fuckboy und so, aber jeder hat einfach seinen Namen und die sprechen sich auch, es gibt dann manchmal so Dokus, wo die dann auch so diese Kommunikation während des Spiels und so und die sprechen sich teilweise auch mit ihrem Nickname an, nicht immer, auch mit ihrem Vornamen und du kannst heißen, wie du willst, jeder kann irgendwie seine eigene Identität bauen und so will ich es auch machen. Ich muss auch sagen, diese ganze Twitch-Bubble oder YouTuber-Bubble, die jetzt alle noch bei Dehner und Laser Luca und diese ganze ... Ach, Dehner ist so eine alte Refle. Ich weiß, aber so ... Es ist so alt. Ja, das stimmt. Aber diese ganzen ... Nee, aber hier so Babys, Babys, Beauty Brothers. Ja, auch Julia Beautix. Du bist ja gar nicht mehr drin. Ach komm. Sag mal, muss ich dir mal Nachhilfe
geben in die Internetkultur?
Die neuen YouTuber, die auf Start sind. Papa Platte.
Ja, wow, mega Name, mega cool,
gar nicht cringe, Papa Platte.
Reese.
Ich weiß, der hört. Reift.
Reese, dem Papa Platte, den Podcast hat.
Ich glaube, der
hat mal gesagt, dass er uns hört. Von daher, liebe
Grüße. Ah ja, liebe Grüße, ja. Aber auch da. Aber Stefan ist zu cool. Stefan liest Bücher von Nick de Vries. Von Nick de Vries? Von dem Typen, von Formel-1-Fahrer. Aber ich schreibe halt Erotik. Ja, ja, ja, stimmt schon. Ja, klar, man muss ja auch gucken, wo man bleibt. Ja, stimmt, aber ich sag alle Namen auf den Tisch, jeder darf sich mal einen nehmen, jeder darf sich Nicknames geben und so kommt der Ehre an. Ich bin dafür wie so Nummernschilder. Also man muss die eintragen, jeden darf es nur einmal geben, es sind Zahlen erlaubt, Sonderzeichen und dann kannst du was eintragen, was es noch nicht gibt. Aber keine Leerzeichen. Keine Leerzeichen. Hab ich keinen Bock drauf. Du kannst eine weisse Eins oder so nehmen? Ja, da hält dich niemand von ab. Aber da musst du halt gucken, auf schwarzem Hintergrund. Sieht man das. Schwierig, siehst du halt die schwarze Eins. Das ist ein Riesenproblem. Genau. Das ist ein Riesenproblem. Aber ansonsten 2025 wird vielleicht ein musikalisches Jahr. Für mich mein Spotify-Rap war eine absolute Katastrophe. Okay, einen Punkt dafür bekommst, bei deinem Brand Predictions, dass 2025 vielleicht ein musikalisches Jahr wird. Und da lege ich mich fest. Mark my words. Da kriegt mich, nee, da kannst du mich auch nicht überzeugen. Ich sage, 2025 wird vielleicht ein musikalisches Jahr., okay und da, nein, meißel mich in Stein nagelt mich fest da bin ich unumstößlich und das Kinosterben wird das weiter vorangehen? Kinosterben wird langsam weiter vorangehen und da wirklich könnt ihr gerne am Ende des Jahres nochmal darauf zurückkommen, aber ich muss sagen, ich muss mir im Riemen reißen, weil mein Spotify-Rap war eine absolute Katastrophe ich hab hast ja dann immer so deine Playlist mit den Songs des Jahres. Ja, wir leben alle im gleichen Vers. Genau, nicht jeder nutzt Spotify. Dann habe ich die ersten zehn Songs gehört, dachte ich mir, stimmt, an die erinnere ich mich. Und alle anderen Songs habe ich noch nie gehört. Das waren irgendwelche Songs, die ich einmal aus irgendeiner Playlist irgendwie drin hatte. Absolute Katastrophe. Ich habe, glaube ich, dieses Jahr einfach drei Songs gehört. Und es war nichts. Ich muss meinen Horizont erweitern, ich muss mehr raus in die Musikalität rein, ich muss mal wieder die E-Gitarre anstecken, ich muss mal wieder raus. Ich habe keine Klang im Kopf. Richard Wagner wurde verdrängt auf Platz zwei. Und auf Platz eins, wir alle wissen, es sind die Prinzen. Das ist alles nur geklaut. Ejo, e oh, das kriegst du einfach nicht genug. Du kriegst einfach nicht genug. Paul Simon. Paul Simon auf Platz eins, Richard Wagner auf Platz zwei. Wo dazwischen ist irgendwo Stefan. Der Stefan, den wir kennen, irgendwo dazwischen steckt er. Ich muss nur sagen, wenn ich jetzt sage, ich will, dass es ein musikalischeres Jahr wird, meine ich, ich muss mehr meine Spotify-Playlist fälschen, um am Ende eine bessere Playlist zu haben. So, ich will nicht mehr hören, ich muss nur präziser das Ganze fälschen, indem ich einfach coole Alben hoch und runter höre, nicht so viel Regen, dieser scheiß Regen, der mir alle Playlists kaputt macht und auch immer meine Playlist der Woche, wo du immer fucking Regen drin hast und immer so Wüstensound und so. Ich habe sehr wenig Musik gehört, vor allem, ich habe glaube ich nur 24.000 Minuten, das war immer deutlich mehr. Es war kein Musikjahr für mich, es war ein Podcastjahr wieder, viel Podcast gehört, sehr viel gehört und dann lieber das als Musik.
Weil auch ich habe keine Lust mehr auf Sport, da hinzugehen. Finde ich grauenhaft die Vorstellung. Ja. Und das Einzige, was mich dazu bringt, ist, Hörbuch oder Podcast zu hören, weil dann denke ich mir, okay, dann mache ich nebenbei Sport. Und dann kann ich von mir rechtfertigen. Also wenn ich sozusagen mir einrede, die Hauptaktivität ist es, einen Podcast oder ein Buch zu hören, dann denke ich mir, das ist cool, das ist eine normale, coole Beschäftigung, die erweite beim Horizont. Und nebenbei mache ich halt noch Sport, cool, das macht mich gesund. Das interessiert mich nicht, das lässt mich besser aussehen. Aber das alleine schaffe ich nicht. Ich schaffe es nicht, mit Musik zum Sport zu gehen. Ich kriege das nicht hin, motivationstechnisch. Flotin. Ich habe lange keinen Sport gemacht, mein Körper ist in einer schlechten Verfassung, wie schon lange nicht mehr. Ich habe ständig Rückenschmerzen, wenn ich einmal ein bisschen was mache, habe ich zwei Rückenschmerzen. Habe ich auch mit Sport, es ist eher schlechter geworden. Meine Rückenschmerzen sind ganz schlimm, ich kann ab und zu einmal im Jahr nicht gehen, weil ich meinen unteren Rücken zerschiesse. Auch jetzt, auch an alle Hörer und Hörer, der Podcast wird sich ändern. Wir werden, der körperliche Fall nimmt weiter zu. Ich hatte ja letztes Jahr dieses Kapaltunnelsyndrom-Ding, wo ich bei der Handärztin war, die mir die Hand gegeben hat. Ich war überfordert, wusste nicht, was soll ich jetzt machen. Gut, du bist jetzt auch bald 40. Ich bin jetzt Mitte 50 langsam und dann ist das Ding und dann habe ich diese erbärmlichen Armschienen bekommen, weswegen ich jetzt jeden Morgen aufwache und mich schlage und nicht aus dem Bett komme, weil ich gefesselt bin an diese Armschienen, die ich tragen muss und die ich jeden Morgen vergesse. Eine andere Origin-Story von Darth Vader. Weil der
wurde so plötzlich, Schlag auf Schlag
wurde ja dieser
Mechatron-Mann.
Ja. Und bei dir fängt es halt da an,
Kapal-Tunnel-Syndrom. Genau, Stück für Stück.
Und ich vergesse es jeden Morgen. Ich wache jeden
Morgen auf und denke, warum kann ich mich nicht bewegen?
Ach so, in der Arm schien.
Aber jeder Morgen beginnt mit Zappelei
und ich versuche, mich loszureißen. Absolute Katastrophe und dann sollte ich eigentlich noch einen Termin beim Neurologen kriegen. Vergiss es, unmöglich, absolut unmöglich, gibt es nicht. Ja, Deutschland geht vor die Hunde. Deutschland geht vor die Hunde, es gibt niemanden, der sich für Nerven interessiert, ist ein super interessantes Thema. Nee, weil die Nerven liegen blablabra. Richtig, er kriegt keinen Termin, schon seit Monaten nicht und jetzt gebe ich auf und denke mir, gut, bin ich halt kaputt. Fühlen. Ja, ist das, ich fange jetzt an, gehe zum Arzt bald, der Check-up mit 30. Oh, ja. Ich bin ja 30 geworden und da habe ich jetzt aber auch schon, merke ich gerade, das halbe Jahr verpasst. Da sollte ich jetzt dringend zum Check-up mit 30 gehen. Ja, finde ich gut. Aber das ist so jetzt völlig, um es in Zukunft zu gucken, das war ja der grosse Jahrespublik, um ein bisschen nach vorne zu gucken, würde ich sagen, geht mal zum Arzt. Vorsatz, mehr zum Arzt. Genau, Vorsatz, Voruntersuchung. Je mehr zum Arzt gehen, desto schwieriger kriegen wir Termine. Macht doch mal 26 für euch, zum grossen Arzt. Ihr seid ja jung, ihr seid ja jung und spritzig. Wenn unsere Statistiken das hergeben, dann seid ihr ungefähr 14. Glaubst du, dass unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer älter, jünger oder gleich alt sind? Ich glaube, also ich habe natürlich die Daten. Ich habe auch die Daten. Aber die sind mittlerweile von 2024. Also man könnte sagen, es sind alte Daten. Und daraus lässt sich natürlich schliessen, dass es einige Alte, einige Junge und viele in der Mitte gibt und die ungefähr so um uns herum schwirren tatsächlich. Aber eher älter als wir. Nee, es gibt schon einige älter, aber ich weiß noch nicht, wo diese Daten herkommen, also wo die genau gesammelt werden, wo die gefasst werden, ob das so vertraulich ist alles, weil ich höre auch Podcasts und meine Daten sind alle falsch. Meine Daten sind alle falsch. Ich habe Fake-Accounts, meine Daten sind komplett falsch, ich bin in manchen Accounts bin ich 260 Jahre alt und das würde ich wahrscheinlich denken mir so, okay, ich höre diesen Podcast und werde deren Statistik wahrscheinlich ziemlich ruinieren, weil ich einfach aus Jux lache. Ehrlich neulich einen Bericht über dich habe ich gesehen bei Brisant, ältestem Mensch der Welt.
Ja, ich habe auch schon Anfragen gekriegt, ich kriege da Mails, ich kriege Briefe.
Mein Problem ist, ich weiß nicht, wie ich darauf reagieren soll, weil klar würde ich gerne die Prämie annehmen.
Du kriegst ja da irgendwie so einen Geschenkgutschein, wenn du der älteste Mensch der Welt bist,
kriegst du gleich da von Norma, kriegst du seine 80 Euro.
Und die könnte ich ganz gut gebrauchen, aber wenn ich da jetzt natürlich auftauche und sage, ich bin 280 Jahre alt, ja, das glaubt mir bei dem Gesicht keiner. Und deswegen ist es natürlich schwierig, wie ich da jetzt rangehe. Ich habe schon mit verschiedenen Make-up-Artists gesprochen, ob man da was machen kann, ob ich unter so einem Hoodie kann, irgendwie mit maskiert, mit einem Schal oder sowas in der Richtung, aber alles Sackgassen, alles Sackgassen, keine Chance. Sackgassen. Alles Sackgassen. Sackgasse. Call the sack. Ja. Ist auch Sackgasse mit drin, auf eine Art. Was ist Call the sack? Wenn der Hammer. Wenn der Hammer? Was ist das? Ich hab grad darüber nachgedacht. Sackgassen. Sagen Amerikaner nicht, call the sack? Oh, das weiß ich gar nicht. Dead End, oder? Ja, aber ich habe auch an einem Call the Sack gewohnt. Früher. In einer Sackgasse. Aber ist es eine Sackgasse, wenn unten so ein Rondell ist, wenn du so mit Schwung wieder rausfahren kannst? Eine sehr deutsche Beschreibung dessen wäre Wendehammer. Wahnsinnig viele Kreisverkehre gefahren letztes Jahr, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Aber das ist eine gute Entwicklung. Ja, wir kommen ja gleich noch zum Rückblick. Und deswegen war es für mich sehr, sehr viel Kreisverkehr stocksauer immer über Leute, die im im Kreisverkehr nicht blinken und auch noch saurer über Leute,
die beim Einfahren in Kreisverkehr blinken,
dadurch eine riesen Verwirrung führen,
weil ich stehe dran, denke, ah, der will
rausfahren, fahr und der fährt ihn aber nicht raus,
sondern es kommt fast zu einem Crash,
wo ich wirklich kurz davor war, ich fahre dem hinterher
und sag dem,
Alter, nicht beim Einfahren blinken,
weil das ist ja kein Böswille,
sondern es ist einfach nur
ein, ich habe die falschen
Daten, kann ich nicht
Vielen Dank. Alda, nicht beim Einfahren blinken so, weil das ist ja kein Böswille, sondern es ist einfach nur ein, ich habe die falschen Daten.
Kann ich nicht das, was die Polizei hat, die Anzeigen oben bitte folgen und so, das möchte ich für Autos und dann schreibe ich dann da mit einem Laptäppchen, ich fahre mit, 180 auf die Autobahn, und schreibt nebenbei so einen Fuß am Lenkrad und die anderen
tippen dann in dieses sehr schlechte,
benutzerunfreundliche Feld,
tippen die, wo du mit so einer, du hast nur so
ein Dreh, ein Drehding, so ein
Drehpoti
und dann muss man dann S und dann muss man
immer so nicht herdrehen, ja.
draufdrücken und dann kriegt man das und so gibt man
das dann ein und dann schreibe ich rein, bitte das nächste Mal nicht blinken Sie Arschloch. Genau. Ja, so ein Messaging-System oder einfach so Klappen, die man aufklappen kann. Ich bin ja auch weiterhin noch auf einem Kreuzzug zum Thema Ruheabteil und, ähm, Kreuzfahrt. Also da, da könnt ihr euch ja jetzt beschweren, dass ich da unkonstruktiv bin, aber es gibt ja, wenn du zum Beispiel über der Bahn ein Ticket buchst, dann so, ja, wollen Sie in unserer Umfrage teilnehmen? Und ich weiß, dass es nichts bringt, aber nehmt es als emotionales Statement, ich brauche das für mich. Und dann machst du so eine Umfrage so, wie hat ihn, waren Sie mit der Buchung heute zufrieden? Und dann würden Sie sagen, ja, nein oder Anmerkung und man darf selber schreiben. Und ich schreibe in das Feld, kümmert euch um das scheiß Ruhabteil. So, das wollen die nicht wissen, darum geht es nicht. Das ist wahrscheinlich ein ganz anderes Department, das sich um die Online-Buchungen kümmern, als die. Aber ich nutze jede Textbox und mittlerweile auch ausserhalb der Bahn-Webseite. Jede Textbox, die mir irgendwo angeboten wird, nutze ich als die Deutsche Bahn soll sich um den Ruhebereich kümmern. Ich frage mich, wenn ich jetzt bei der Bahn arbeiten würde, welche Umfragen würde ich ernst nehmen? Und ich glaube, es wären die, die nicht nur schlechte Bewertungen geben. Ich glaube, und so mache ich, ich gebe ja bei Umfragen, bin ich ja immer super ehrlich. Auch so ein Hotel, was ich gehasst habe, oder eine Bahnfahrt, die ich gehasst habe, aber in eine rissene Umfrage. Und manchmal sind die aber schlecht gestellt. Dann sind sie sowas wie, wie war der Bahnservice bei ihnen? Ja, der war gut. Darum geht's jetzt ja nicht. Ich bin super wütend auf euch, aber der war super. Fünf Sterne. Das Bahnpersonal. Wie hat das Bahnpersonal so? Ja, die fucking kam zwei Stunden zu spät. An denen liegt's ja nicht. Fünf Sterne. Und ich hab so eine Krawatte, aber wenn man mich sieht, wenn man mir von hinten um die Schulter gucken würde, polternder, roter Kopf, fünf Sterne, fünf Sterne, fünf Sterne. Wann fragt du nach den richtigen Dingen? Fünf Sterne. Wie war die Klimaanlage? Fünf Sterne. Ja, die Bahnen sind immer lächerlich sauber, fünf Sterne, ich hasse es, ich komme nicht an mein Ziel, wie waren die Toiletten, fünf fucking fünf Sterne und das ist so spannend, weil fragt mich nach den richtigen Dingen, die mich abfacken. Und dann am Ende ist so mein Durchschnitt 4,8 Sterne, weil ich dann nur unten bei Pünktlichkeit oder bei Ruheabteil oder so habe ich dann einen Stern gegeben. Und die klopfen sich auf die Schulter und sagen, oh 4,8, das ist ja super, das ist ja wunderbar. Leute, wir machen jetzt Feierabend. Deswegen auch niemals einen Stern geben, habe ich für mich gelernt, niemals einen Stern geben, wenn du was schlecht fandest, immer zwei Sterne geben. Weil bei zwei Sternen denkt sich der, ah, da ist noch Potenzial da, der hat uns noch nicht aufgegeben, der ist rational, mit dem kann man arbeiten, ein Stern ist, ihr seht mich nie wieder, ihr wichst, ich bin raus, so. Ist ja auch egal, weil der ist eh weg. Aber weil zwei Sternen, deswegen immer nur zwei Sterne geben, da bin ich dabei.
Aufgefallen ist bei Bahnen, die sind wie so Muscheln. Wenn es gut läuft, kommen die Bahnmitarbeiter rausgekrochen. Und wenn es schlecht läuft und die Bahn ist verspätet oder alles läuft schief und lächerlich, dann sieht man niemanden. Komplett voll gestopft.
Du siehst keinen fucking Schaffner.
Nix.
Wo ich mich bei der Frage erwische, ich wurde noch nicht kontrolliert, er ist super voll, alle stehen im Gang und sitzen im Gang, wie käme der hier überhaupt durch, stellt sich die Frage, weil er kommt gar nicht erst durch. Ich stelle mir vor, wie die in ihrem Schützengraben sind, einfach irgendwie so und einfach nur da ausharren und sich einfach verstecken irgendwo. Und dann wirklich, dann kommen sie rum und fragen, darf es etwas aus dem Bordbistro sein? Wenn es gut läuft, dann kommen sie so raus, wie so eine Muschel. Und dann ziehen sie sich wieder ein. Wie so eine Pistazie, wo du, dann die, die ganz offen sind, die kriegst du locker auf. Aber die sind nicht, die dich interessieren. Mich interessieren die Pistazien, die keinen fucking Schlitz haben, wo ich mit meinem fucking Daumenfingernagel da irgendwie reinpule, irgendwie mir komplettes Fingerbett kaputt mache. Ich habe super viele Pips. Wir haben mal vor langer Zeit gefragt nach Minimalsdialekten, von Kleinstdialekten und irgendeine Hörerin hat geschrieben, in ihrer Familie heißt es Pips, wenn man so kleine, verhärtete Hautstücke an den Fingern hat und die sich so runterzieht und dann zu weit zieht und dann schneiden die ins Fleisch und dann hat man eine offene Stelle und dann wird es immer schlimmer und dann
krustet das und reißt es immer mehr auf.
Absoluter Horror. Hatte ich dieses Jahr besonders viel.
Geben meine Finger auf?
Ich bilde mir ein, dass ich immer
nur an einem Finger Pips habe.
Oh, das ist so ein, das ist wie so eine Art
Schocken-Pips, der immer wieder neu
gepflanzt wird und immer wieder neu sich erholt,
aber nie wirklich die Wunde sich schliesst.
Boah,
eckige Beschreibung war das jetzt, nochmal.
Ja, aber so ist es, Die Kälte zerstört die Hände. Die Kälte zerstört die Hände. Du hast dich, kleiner Ausblick, beschlossen für 2025, nicht mehr so unsympathisch zurückzuhalten. Du willst jetzt meinungsstark sein, du willst Sachen sagen, wie sie sind. Hose runter, ich bin für alles da, auch für anatomische Ungenauigkeiten bin ich wirklich da. Man muss über Dinge offen reden können, um sie auch zu behandeln und um eine Akzeptanz zu schaffen. Und wir alle haben Schorf, wir alle haben Eiter, wir haben Pickel, Hemoriden, Pilze, irgendwelche komischen Knubbel irgendwo am After, wir haben alles irgendwie an der falschen Stelle. Wir alle sind einfach tiefst kaputte Wesen, aber so wie wir sind auch wunderschön. Ja, also dieses Jahr geht es weiter wie gehabt, wir senden durch, wir freuen uns sehr, vielen Dank für den großen Jahresrückblick Florentin, die grosse Gala, das war heute die richtig grosse Gala. Die grosse Gala, ja, wir haben wirklich den grossen Aufriss malagt. Heute war ja auch Folge 444. 444, das rate ich dir. Ich will aufpassen, das ist so ein Nazi-Ding auch, ne? 444? 444, ja, DDD, Deutschland in Deutschen. Ich glaube, da müssen wir ein bisschen aufpassen. Ah, richtig, okay. Also so nicht ... Du meinst, dass ich das nicht kenne. Nicht, dass, ja, aber deswegen ... Was sagst du über dich aus, dass du das immer auch alles kennst? Also Deswegen, dass der Podcast jetzt nicht so verstanden wird, sondern wir sind, also da möchten wir nichts mit zu tun haben, wir distanzieren uns, das ist schon mal klar. Wir wollen nicht so ins neue Jahr starten, dass ihr jetzt irgendwie zur Feier der Folge irgendwie durch die Straßen zieht und das skandiert, bitte nicht. Macht das gerne ab 445 wieder weiter, das ist die Gift-Hotline nebenbei. 445-445. Wie 116-116. So war es, Entschuldigung, 116-116 ist die Gift-Hotline nebenbei, vier vier fünf vier vier fünf. Wie eins eins sechs, eins eins sechs. So war's, Entschuldigung, eins eins sechs, eins
eins sechs ist die Gift-Hotline. Gibt das für dich den gleichen
Vibe ab? Ich finde schon.
Ich finde, die vier
ist die eins der sechsten.
Also was für die sechs die eins ist, ist für die vier die
eins. Ne, die eins ist die sechs, das ist
wie der nächste Schritt nach der Runden
null oder fünf, also so.
Ja gut. Ne, was für die vier die 6 ist, ist für die 7, die 8. Weil sie rundlich sind. Für die 5 ist es für die 7, die 8. Was für die 1, die 4 ist, ist für die 6, die 5. Das sehe ich ganz genau so. Und siehst du, das ist das große Konsensjahr. Wir kommen zusammen, wir rücken dichter aneinander. Es ist das Kuscheljahr. Es ist das Kuscheljahr, wo ich dich dicht an mich drücken will und wo man auch mal wirklich, also für mich war 2024 das Umarmungs mit Klopfenjahr. Rückblick ist vorbei, ich verstehe jetzt nicht, warum. Und jetzt aber 2025 ist das Umarmung mit Streicheljahr. Also umarmen und dann nochmal Handfläche hoch und runter. Nicht klopfen, sondern hoch. Und so ins Ohr dröhnen, so mhm, hi. Ja, das kommt auf dem Kontext an, so ein bisschen. Hi, mhm, hi. Ja, weiß ich nicht, ob das ... Was riechst du heute gut? Mhm, hi. Ja, wenn man die Person schon lange sehr gut kennt vielleicht. Ja, ich dachte, uns. Ach so, so begrüßen wir uns jetzt. Nein. Ja, da freue ich mich drauf, dass wir uns jetzt ... Das wird unsagend. Wir werden viele Folgen raushauen in diesem Jahr, ehrlich gesagt. Wie viele? Wir ballern 52 Folgen raus, jede Woche eine, das ziehen wir durch, kein Problem. Und wir ballern und ballern und ballern und dann, glaube ich, sind wir ja, dieses Jahr werden wir noch nicht die 500 knacken, glaube ich. Das wird dann erst 26 passieren, dass wir in die 500er gehen. Und da werde ich mich richtig drauf freuen. Ich habe richtig Bock drauf. Richtig Bock drauf. Ja, wir gehen in unser zehntes Jahr und ich bin sehr, sehr happy und freue mich sehr auf euch und vielen Dank für das letzte Jahr. Wir freuen uns aufs nächste. Schaut im Ufo Club vorbei, guckt mal rein. Das war's für euch, euer Vorsatz, nur als Vorschlag. Euer Vorsatz vielleicht im Ufo Club, schaut mal auf Patron vorbei, 2025 ist ein werbefreies Jahr. Keine Werbung mehr, kriegt schönen Rabatt im Store, könnt ihr schön mit dabei sein, die Folge immer einen Tag früher, macht mal 25 zu eurem Clubjahr. Wir heißen euch willkommen, es gibt immer schöne Bohle,
es gibt tolle Bademäntel, es gibt eine herrliche
Podcast. Das
klappt jetzt inzwischen richtig gut,
außer wenn Florentinzendien manchmal ausgeht, aber
ansonsten klappt das richtig gut.
Freuen wir uns sehr drüber über den Videopodcast.
Das macht auch noch
richtig toll Spaß. Guckt mal rein, schaut mal rein,
ob das was für euch ist. Ansonsten freuen wir uns
sehr auf das kommende Jahr mit euch, liebe Puffonauten. Mit dir. Stefan, ich freue mich auf ein neues Jahr mit dir. Wir werden wieder tolle Shows spielen. Ja, wir machen Improv. Das macht sehr viel Spaß, da freue ich mich sehr drauf. Die Shows waren richtig toll. Vielen Dank an alle, die rumgekommen sind, wahrscheinlich größtenteils. Da lehne ich mich jetzt nicht so weit aus dem Fenster Puffo-Fans im weissten Sinne. Macht Spaß, euch zu sehen. Wir freuen uns sehr auf die weiteren Impro-Shows.
Im Januar geht es weiter jetzt mit München.
Ja, und dann schauen wir mal, wie es weitergeht. Haut rein, macht's gut.
Auf jeden Fall, bis zum nächsten Mal. Habt ein schönes Jahr.
Haut rein, tschüss, wir heben ab, bis zum nächsten Mal. It's the worst bird production.seits vom Standard, willkommen im Ruhrgebiet, echt statt inszeniert, jede Ecke anders, jede Story echt, späti-Romantik an der Trinkhalle, Beats unterm Förderturm, Sonnenuntergang auf der Halde, klingt anders, ist es auch, dein Ruhrgebiet, wo das Unperfekte perfekt passt, Inspiration für deinen Next-Level-Städtetrip gibt's auf Insta, mein.ruhrgebiet. Mein Bruderherz, wir müssen einmal noch den Promospot für unseren Podcast aufnehmen. Zeig mal her, Wild und Fremd, Podcast über historische Expeditionen, ganz nah an den persönlichen Tagebüchern, der Entdecker. Kannst du die Musik bitte ausmachen? Ja, sorry. Müssen wir sagen, dass wir 2024 den Deutschen Podcastpreis gewonnen haben? Auf jeden Fall, wir müssen ganz oft auch unseren Namen sagen,
wild und fremd, wild und fremd, wild und fremd, damit die Leute unbedingt draufklicken.
Glaubst du wirklich, dass es jetzt irgendwelche Leute hören und extra noch wild und fremd googeln?
Mal schauen.